aujourd'hui tv tours val de loire vous
emmène à la découverte d'un monument
bien connue des tourangeaux latour
charlemagne mais pas pour une simple
visite non pour un escape game organisé
par aesc et purcell et suivez moi
depuis le début du mois de juillet ce
bâtiment du 11e siècle abrite un jeu à
la règle claire sortir de la pièce dans
le temps imparti là où nous retrouvons
nos coéquipiers du jour la famille jez
accompagné de kevin le maître du jeu
alors c'est parti
on m'a dit vous avez une heure seulement
une heure et le début de la partie il
faut tout observer tous touchés et ne
rien laisser au hasard pour franchir les
différentes étapes du jeu donc être
continue on a réussi à ouvrir une
première porte
oui partout des cadenas à chiffre à
l'être et de nombreuses énigmes
dissimulés dans les pièces au temps de
jeu surprenant mêlant décor historique
et technologies finalement avec un peu
de patience et de débrouillardise une
victoire à laquelle excitation arfelis
conçu pour des personnes de tous âges
l'escape games semble ravir les joueurs
c'était très cool parce que finalement
il ya on est un peu perdu au début il ya
plein d'énigmes à faire et on est plongé
dans l'histoire un petit peu moi j'adore
ça et en plus j'adore fuis moi j'adore
les coins secrets les petits trucs à
fouiner les trucs où personne ne rentre
sûreté générale est-ce que j'ai bien
aimé se replonger on va dans la propre
histoire au niveau tourangelle et ça
franchement c'est le côté sympa ça nous
permet de le recaler nos tristes notre
propre histoire et puis de profiter de
ce lieu qui est magnifique pour le
créateur du jeu le cadre est primordial
il était donc important de respecter la
tour charlemagne un endroit qui était
pas encore assez exploité selon moi que
les tourangeaux en avait envie de mieux
connaître et après il ya le respect
historique du lieu fin moi il est hors
de question que je fasse en escrime cas
aucun rapport avec le lieu dans lequel
je me trouve donc quand j'ai conçu ce
scénario il fallait que ça colle à
l'histoire de la ville il fallait que ça
réponde à l'histoire de la tour
charlemagne pour nous c'est cool parce
qu'il ya déjà une âme dans le lieu donc
c'est plus facile les skates game de la
tour charlemagne restera ouvert au moins
jusqu'à la fin du mois de septembre pour
les retardataires pas de panique
laventure reprendra dès le printemps
prochain